[Musique]
quel bonheur quelle joie quelle émotion
de vous retrouver si nombreux nous
n'avons rien abandonné nous n'avons pas
dévié et aujourd'hui nous sommes de
retour
d'elle à nos principes fidèles à un
immense de voir de lucidité se dit hier
qui avait nourri nos succès et qui sont
partis que ce soit vers Marine Le Pen
ouvert Emmanuel Macron je leur dis de ne
plus se laisser abuser nouvelle fois
revenez revenez au porter avec nous
cette espérance française raviver
revenez tout simplement pour que nous
puissions redonner aux françaises et aux
Français foi en l'avenir revenez pour
que nous redressions ce pays
ce pays que nous aimons passionnément
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]